i recently had an article
on stronger by science called do oral
contraceptives affect your gains
and uh yeah so it was looking at this
question
it was nominally a review of a study by
oxfelt and colleagues called molecular
markers of skeletal muscle hypertrophy
following 10 weeks of resistance
training and oral contraceptive users
and non-users um see it was nominally a
review of that study but mostly i just
wanted to
just broadly review the literature
looking at the impact of hormonal
contraceptives on strength and
hypertrophy outcomes in female lifters
because i think this is a topic where
there
at least seems to be a fair bit of
misinformation and a fair bit of
scaremongering fake news fake news yeah
um and i think that
i mean i think a lot of it just kind of
goes back to just some version of the
naturalistic fallacy where or an appeal
to nature where
you know
you just kind of assume that if you're
putting
synthetic hormones into your body
since that's not natural something bad
must happen uh and uh maybe it's gonna
kill your gains like whatever um
like i i think that's kind of the kernel
of the of the line of reasoning that
leads
a lot of influencers on social media to
just
flatly recommend that uh women in their
audience not use hormonal contraceptives
um you know they they say it's going to
make it harder to build muscle attain
positive training adaptations and
the thing is like that was
maybe a tenable position
five years ago
because there just wasn't that much
research on it
and you know with with anything it's not
that hard to find negative anecdotes
about
virtually anything that someone could do
so there's not that much research
there's plenty of negative anecdotes and
you're like well okay like
maybe this isn't a good idea uh but
within the last five years or so there
have been quite a few studies looking
like you know studying in a controlled
way
the impact of uh oral hormonal
contraceptives on strength and
hypertrophy outcomes and
they just find that it it doesn't really
seem to matter uh it doesn't seem to
make much of a difference so at this
point there have been uh 10 papers
published from eight discrete studies
comparing strength lean mass hypertrophy
outcomes in users and non-users of oral
contraceptives undergoing the same
resistance training program
um
and
by and large they find
really no meaningful difference and if
you're if you're the type of person who
uh more enjoys a
liberal interpretation of research
results we're like i don't care about
statistical significance i don't
necessarily need to see a meta-analysis
that that confirms that within this body
of literature one thing or the other is
better
if you're someone who more just
you know wants wants to look and see
where the wind is blowing like is this
inconclusive body of literature leaning
in one direction or the other uh if at
this point it is leaning in one
direction or the other it's actually
leaning in the direction of
oral contraceptives maybe improving
hypertrophy outcomes i and i'm not
making that as like a strong claim like
they will definitely help you build more
muscle uh i i personally think it
doesn't make any material difference uh
but if if the literature is leaning one
way or the other
that seems to be the way that it's
leaning right now
and like i said at this point it's not
just based on
just one isolated study or one or two
papers like there's you know there's ten
papers in this area which
you know
as with most things in our field i would
love to see a larger body of research on
this you know like 30 papers are better
than 10. uh but 10 is a lot better than
than for a lot of questions uh in our
area and they're painting like this body
of of literature is painting a pretty
cohesive picture like you
you can look at the results of these
studies there's a table uh linked in the
stronger by science article uh that you
can check out
let's see it is table
table five in the article uh that that
just breaks down all of the results of
these studies and
uh yeah if
if
oral contraceptives do negatively impact
your gains
it has not been observed in the
literature to this point
um see i i don't
really feel like i need to go super in
depth about the oxfield paper uh
in particular uh but i i did just want
to note that like if if someone does
want to claim that oral contraceptives
negatively affect strength and
hypertrophy outcomes
just know that whatever they're using to
make that claim
isn't based on actual longitudinal human
evidence because the longitudinal human
evidence does not support
uh
fear and trepidation around oral
contraceptives
negatively affecting hypertrophy or
strength outcomes